الى الولايات المتحده التي تجتاحها منذ
ايام عاصفه ثلجيه قويه يقول الخبراء انها
من النوع الذي لا ياتي سوى مره واحده في
كل جيل قرابه 15 الف رحله جويه الغيت
وانقطع التيار الكهربائي عن اكثر من مليون
شخص
واغلقت عقبه من كومات الثلج المتراكمه
عددا من الطرقات في عموم انحاء البلاد وقد
ارتفع عدد الى الامريكيين الذين لقوا
مصرعهم جرى العاصفه الى 55 25 منهم قضوا
امس فقط في مدينه ففلو في ولايه نيويورك
التي وصفت حاكمتها المشهد فيها بانه اشبه
بساحه حرب ماذا فعل الرئيس بيضا الى اعلان
حاله الطوارئ
من واشنطن ينضم الينا مراسله جزيره ناصر
الحسيني ناصر ما الذي سترتب الان على
اعلان حاله الطوارئ اذا من قبل الرئيس
بيضا وايضا ما الذي يجعله ينتظر حتى الان
ليعلنها
يعني حجمه او حجمه المفاجاه في هذه
العاصفه كان هائلا لم يكن احد يتوقع ان
تكون هذه العاصفه او تتحول هذه العاصفه
الثلجيه التي اعتادت عليها ولايات شمال
الولايات المتحده لم تكن هناك توقعات
دقيقه حقيقه بان تتحول فجاه الى عاصفه
القطبيه رياح قويه بلغت بعض الحالات 80
كيلو متر في الساعه بثلوج قويه وكثيفه
استمرت لعده ساعات واتت من كندا واشتحت
الاراضي الامريكيه الى العمق الامريكي
ثم توجهت نحو الشرق الان منذ يومين تقريبا
انتهت العاصفه كعاصفه لكن الولايات
المتحده تعيش اثارها واثار لم تنتهي بعد
اليوم ما هو في توقعات ان مدينه بصل التي
اصبحت شهيره الان بعدد قتلاها وكميه
الثلوج التي تسقط فيها ما زالت هناك ثلوج
ربما خمسه الى
خمسه الى
متوقع هذا اليوم وستكون النهايه في هذا
المسلسل الذي شهد مقتل 28 شخصا في مدينه
بافلو وحولها فقط اي ولايه نيويورك وال 28
الاخرون في مختلف الولايات واختلفت اشكال
الوفاه في هذه العاصفه الثلجيه غير مسبوقه
ويعاصفه قطبيه تاريخيه لم تشهدها جيل كامل
من الامريكيين همم اسباب الوفاه كلها
مرتبطه بهذه العاصفه هناك من توفي على
الطرقات اي ان قياده السيارات اصبحت
مستحيله في لحظات الماء كان الناس يقودون
سياراتهم على الطرقات فجاه ريح قويه
وكثيفه اضطر الوقوف والبقاء هناك عده
ساعات الى ان حصلت ووفات والان فرق
الانقاذ تنتشر حول مدينه بصلوا في محاوله
منها للحصول على الاولى وهم بالمئات على
ما يبدوا على جوانب بطرقات مختلفه مناطق
الولايه رئيس بلده تدخل بتوفر الميزانيات
والكثير من فرق الدعم اتصل الان الى مجيد
بصلوا لوجين خاص في محاوله منهالين قاذبه
يمكن انقاذه ما زال الحظر على السياقه
سائر حتى الان اشكرك من واشنطن مراسل
الجزيره ناصر الحسين